So here is my solution: I've takan all the input parameters,
and the very first thing is I've set the dimension of the matrix and the vector:
the length of the Path, plus the number of Landmarks--
times 2--because I'm modeling x and y
for each of those, in the same data structures.
I then create a matrix for Omega and a vector for Xi,
give it the appropriate dimensions,
and subsequently I introduce the constraint
that the initial positions have to be world-size/2.0,
with a strength value of 1.0,
That tells it this has no bearing on the final solutions
because it's the only absolute constraint.
But you can see--I add 1.0 over here in the main diagonal:
1 for x and 1 for y--
and then now add the same thing over here.
It's important to understand how I set up the data structure.
There's our positions--and let me just, for a second, call them "S".
And there's our landmarks.
Each of those have an x-component and a y-component.
So in doing this, I'm taking this matrix and I'm setting it up,
not by a matrix of Path length plus the number of landmarks,
but each of those becomes a 2 by 2 matrix,
where I explicitly retain the x and the y value.
So the dimension here is 2 times N--the Path length--
plus the number of landmarks.
And the 2 is the result of modeling x and y: xy, xy, xy.
That's really important for my solution.
You might have done this differently--you might have said:
I'm going to build 1 matrix for x and 1 matrix for y.
and then each of those becomes just a single value,
which is closer to the way we discussed it in class.
And that's fine, in this case.
In general, it has disadvantages
in that it cannot correlate X and Ys.
So for a real robot that has real rotations, this doesn't work.
My solution is better, but for this specific example
this would have been perfectly fine.
Coming back to my example, I now process the data.
I go through all the data items
and my Path index is now the data item, times 2--
which is the xy thing.
I extract my measurements from the data--
my motion from the data--
using this command over here;
and then I go through all the measurements,
of which they are my multiple ones.
I find the index in my matrix of the measurement,
which is the Path plus the measurement index,
times 2--because there are X and Ys again.
And then the next routine just implements
the simple addition with the measurement_noise
as the inverse weighting factor.
So it adds: 1, 1, -1, -1
to the corresponding elements in the submatrix,
and in the vector, it adds the measurement--
all divided by the strength of the noise variable.
If you look at this carefully,
you'll take a minute to digest it
and what was the use in the auxilliary variable, b,
to account for the effect of this x and y.
So b goes from zero to 1.
And these are all the combinations.
You have to stare at them to make sure they are all correct,
but I can promise you--they're actually all correct.
Motion is handled very much the same way:
I extract the Motion command,
I add among, the main diagonal--
between the 2 variables that are being tied together--a "+1",
and then I add, in the off-diagonal elements,"-1".
So again, you have to stare at this
very carefully to see they're all correct.
And then I add the Motion itself to the vector, Xi.
That's what I had to implement.
I then solve, as before, and return the solution.
And that's exactly what's being printed out down here.
I have to say, we got this correct--I'm mightily impressed.
You understood a lot about Mapping
and you solved a really hard programming problem.
I'm responding to some of you online
who asked for challenging programming problems.
This is a challenging piece of code to write.
It took myself a number of hours to write,
and that would be wonderful if you got it right.